[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis schönen guten Abend an diesem
Donnerstag der Sport mit Norbert Lehmann
und dem deutschen Fußball-WM Hummels und
Reus raus mukoko rein Götze wieder dabei
später mehr unsere weiteren großen
Themen heute
Ringen um Reformen der Bundestag
beschließt das Bürgergeld doch die Union
will das Gesetz im Bundesrat blockieren
skeps ist über Abzug die Ukraine traut
der Ankündigung eines russischen
Rückzugs aus Hassan nicht
und Kader für Katha Bundespräsident
pflegt präsentiert sein Team für die
Fußball-Weltmeisterschaft mit
Überraschungen und Enttäuschungen
zeitlich wird es knapp mit dem Vorhaben
der Bundesregierung zum ersten Januar
das neue Bürgergeld einzuführen und
damit Hartz IV abzuschaffen im Bundestag
gab es zwar grünes Licht mit den Stimmen
der Ampelkoalition aber das Bürgergeld
muss auch noch durch den Bundesrat und
da droht die Union weiter mit Blockade
schauen wir auf wichtige Änderungen beim
Bürgergeld der Satz für Erwachsene
steigt um 53 Euro auf dann 502 Euro wer
die Unterstützung bekommt darf künftig
mehr Ersparnisse haben und Arbeitslose
sollen weniger mit Sanktionen unter
Druck gesetzt werden die Debatte im
Bundestag jetzt von Las Bohnsack
nicht zufällig hat der Arbeitsminister
diese Firma in Berlin für einen
Pressetermin aus und aufgesucht 5
ehemalige Langzeitarbeitslose haben hier
eine Ausbildung oder Festanstellung
bekommen es gab auch zeigen wir werden
meine Hartz iv-geschichten also der wird
mal irgendwann depressiv wenn man nur zu
Hause sitzt man hat ja auch ein
lebenshinhalt kein Geld und von daher
bin ich heilfroh das ist so gekommen ist
wie es gekommen ist bei
Langzeitarbeitslosen können Arbeitgebern
Lohnzuschüsse bis zu 100% über mehrere
Jahre gewährt werden dieser sogenannte
soziale Arbeitsmarkt soll nun entfristet
und Teil des neuen Bürgergeldes werden
es geht darum dass Menschen die in
existenzielle Not geraten sind
verlässlich und so unbürokratisch wie
möglich abgesichert werden aber das
reicht uns nicht wir wollen nicht nur
Schutz geben in Zeiten der Not wir
wollen Chancen auf den selbstbestimmtes
Leben schaffen massiver Widerstand kommt
von der Union die stört sich vor allem
an den längeren Karenzzeiten und höheren
Schonvermögen es geht eben um ein
Schonvermögen bei einer
Bedarfsgemeinschaft mit zwei Kindern von
150.000 Euro die man besitzen kann und
trotzdem Bürgergeld bekommen kann die
Mehrheit der Arbeitnehmerinnen und
Arbeitnehmer kann von einem solchen
vermögen nur träumen den Vorwurf
Sanktionen würden massiv gelockert nennt
die Ampel Fake News
Prozent der sank
tionen im Monaten weiter verhängt und
danach sogar das volle
verfassungsrechtlich mögliche Maße wer
etwas anderes verbreitet der verbreitet
Fake News und das geht nicht für die
Linkspartei ist das Gesetz vollkommen
unzureichend real ist das eben keine
Abkehr von Hartz IV das System bleibt
erhalten in der Substanz ist es Hartz 5
meine Damen und Herren trotz der
Zustimmung durch den Bundestag ist noch
nicht gesichert dass das Bürgergeld
tatsächlich zum ersten Januar kommt
blockiert die Union wie angekündigt das
Gesetz im Bundesrat muss es in den
Vermittlungsausschuss dessen Ausgang
wäre weitgehend offen
für die Abgeordneten ist es heute eine
marathon-sitzung im Bundestag mit
einigen weiteren wichtigen
Entscheidungen so wurde die sogenannte
dezemberhilfe für Gas- und
fernwärmekundinnen und Kunden
beschlossen als Überbrückung bis die
gaspreisbremse im März oder Februar
nächsten Jahres kommt außerdem die
Reform des Wohngeldes es wird erhöhte
und kommt künftig mehr Menschen zugute
und wegen der hohen Inflation wurden
eine Reihe von steuerlichen Entlastungen
verabschiedet darunter eine Anhebung des
Grundfreibetrages
zum Krieg in der Ukraine und zur Frage
was bedeutet die russische Ankündigung
Teile der Region kasson aufzugeben
Moskau hatte gestern angeordnet Truppen
im Süden des Landes aus der
großstadtkrasson und aus der Gegend
westlich vom Fluss nipro abzuziehen
ukrainische Einheiten Rücken dort vor
und sollen zwölf Ortschaften
zurückerobert haben aber Kiew machen zur
Vorsicht Volker duucek und Sarah Hassan
ZD
von neun Monaten hat Tamara hier noch
ein normales Leben geführt ohne Krieg in
einem intakten Haus nur wo alexandrifka
75 Kilometer nördlich von triason 12.000
Einwohner haben hier früher gelebt die
Russen zogen vor vier Wochen ab doch sie
haben ein Erbe hinterlassen das vielen
Angst macht Minen
weißt du wir haben wieder Strom noch
Wasser nicht viel Brennholz wir könnten
in die Wälder gehen aber wer weiß ob es
dort nicht Sprengfallen gibt
ob die Russen wirklich mit dem Abzug
begonnen haben kaum einer weiß es das
ukrainische militärschweinigt dieses
Video soll Konvois und zurückgelassene
russische Fahrzeuge in der Region rasant
zeigen bis zu 30.000 russische Soldaten
zu schätzen amerikanische Militärs sind
noch in der Region der Abzug wird noch
Tage dauern
Verhalten der Freude bei diesen
ukrainischen Soldaten sie melden die
Rückeroberung eines Ortes doch der
eigene Präsident mahnt zur Vorsicht wenn
er sagt der Feind macht uns keine
Geschenke macht keine Gesten des guten
Willens
Experten und Expertinnen werden die
Ankündigung des truppenrückzuges als ein
Erfolg der Ukraine
vieles deutet momentan darauf hin dass
es wirklich ein Rückzug ausfassung ist
ein geordneter russischer Rückzug aus
Rexon und damit wäre es eine politische
und militärische Niederlage man könnte
glaube ich sogar sagen Demütigung für
Russland weil sie damit nach kurzer Zeit
ein Gebiet verlieren was sie vorgegeben
haben nach Russland integriert zu haben
was sie annektiert haben eine
ukrainische Patrouille unterwegs in der
Region casson das Misstrauen gegenüber
den russischen Abzugsplänen ist bei
vielen noch groß
gehen wir zu unserer korrespondentinnen
in Russland und unserem Korrespondenten
in der Ukraine sie sind nördlich von
chasson Dara Hassan Sade wie geht die
Ukraine militärisch mit der Ankündigung
Russlands um sich aus Hassan
zurückzuziehen
ja die Strategie der ukrainischen Armee
bei der Rückeroberung von herson ist
weiterhin von Vorsicht geprägt langsam
rückt man vor Dorf für Dorf man
überstürzt nichts und bei unseren
frontbesuchen haben wir auch erlebt dass
es den einzelnen Soldaten dort auch zum
Teil zu langsam ginge denn sie war dort
schon seit Wochen und Monaten aber diese
Strategie hat verlustreiche Kämpfe
vermieden und sie scheint jetzt ja auch
von Erfolg gekrönt zu werden
für begann in Moskau und wie wird in
Russland am Tag danach auf die
Entscheidung des russischen Militärs
reagiert
ja wenn man sich heute das
Staatsfernsehen oder auch die Telegramm
Kanäle anschaut dann fällt auf dass
selbst diejenigen diese Entscheidung
loben die vor wenigen Tagen und Wochen
noch die Militärführung scharf
kritisiert haben Russlands Propaganda
Maschinen die läuft also auf Hochtouren
alles soll unternommen werden um die
Russinnen und Russen ja davon zu
überzeugen dass diese Entscheidung
richtig war fast alles denn einer der
schweigt nach wie vor und zwar der
Oberbefehlshaber der russischen Armee
Wladimir Putin der hatte ja vor sechs
Wochen noch verkündet im Zuge der
Annektion von Herr son dass die
Einwohner dort jetzt Russen sein und das
für immer von dieser Jubelstimmung
damals da ist jetzt eigentlich nichts
mehr zu spüren in Moskau und man kann
beobachten das was in diesen Fällen
häufig auftritt nämlich dass sich der
Präsident von negativen Entwicklungen
lieber fernhält danke für Bega und Sarah
hast du uns alle
auch in der Ukraine wird genau auf die
Ergebnisse der Kongresswahlen in den USA
geschaut denn aus den Rhein der
Republikaner werden die Forderungen
lauter die Ukraine nicht mehr so stark
finanziell zu unterstützen
noch sind nicht alle Ergebnisse der
us-zwischenwahlen da aber es sieht
danach aus das ist knappe
Mehrheitsverhältnisse im
Repräsentantenhaus und im Senat geben
könnte wenn er mir Daniel
die rund um die Uhr Berichterstattung
läuft noch immer denn nach wie vor sind
nicht alle Stimmen ausgezählt beobachter
glauben dass es am Ende das Beste
zwischenwahlergebnis für einen
amtierenden Präsidenten seit 20 Jahren
werden könnte Joe Biden hat also allen
Grund zum Lachen
du hast ein guter Tag für die Demokratie
und ein guter Tag für Amerika unsere
Demokratie wurde in den vergangenen
Jahren herausgefordert aber mit ihren
Stimmen haben die Amerikaner gesprochen
und bewiesen dass Demokratie das ist was
uns ausmacht
besonders knapp ist das senats-rennen im
schlüsselstaat Georgia weil keiner der
Kandidaten 50% der Stimmen bekam wird es
eine Stichwahl geben und so könnte es
sogar sein dass erst im Dezember klar
ist wer künftig die Senatsmehrheit in
hat
sollte es so kommen wie viele Beobachter
jetzt Vorhersagen also dass die
Republikaner eben nur eine hauchdünne
Mehrheit im Repräsentantenhaus haben
werden und die Demokraten vielleicht
sogar den Senat verteidigen können in
diesem Szenario hätte Joe Biden
zumindest die Chance manche große Linie
seiner Politik auch weiterhin umzusetzen
mit ihren großen Themen wie Abtreibung
und Demokratie Erhalt konnten die
Demokraten also Punkten auch bei vielen
jungen Wählern die Republikaner hingegen
müssen sich fragen ob der radikale Kurs
den Donald Trump fährt der Partei nicht
eher schadet denn die Zwischenwahlen
haben unter anderem gezeigt dass den
Menschen nicht nur das eigene
Portemonnaie wichtig ist
US-Präsident beiden und Chinas Präsident
chising Ping kommen am Montag erstmals
seit beiden Amtsantritt zu einem
bilateralen treffen zusammen und zwar
beim G20-Gipfel auf Bali
italien hatte die Ocean Viking
abgewiesen nun darf das Rettungsschiff
mit gut 200 Menschen in Frankreich
anlegen seit mehr als zwei Wochen kreuzt
der Seenotretter der Hilfsorganisation
SOS Mediterranee im Mittelmeer weil
Italiens extrem rechte Regierung ein
Hafen verweigerte Frankreich verurteilte
das Verhalten Roms und erwartet das
Schiff morgen in Tulum von den 234
Flüchtlingen wollen nun Deutschland und
Frankreich je ein Drittel aufnehmen
alle die ein Handy haben werden in den
kommenden Tagen mit einer SMS über das
neue katastrophen-warnsystem cell
broadcast informiert das Kündigen die
großen Mobilfunkprovider an die
wahlnachrichten des Systems erreichen
alle Handys die in einer Funkzelle
eingebucht sind ohne dass eine App dafür
nötig ist am 8 dezember soll das neue
Warnsystem erstmals bundesweit getestet
werden
wer bekommt auf der Intensivstation noch
ein Beatmungsgerät wenn nicht mehr genug
für alle da sind ein gewaltiges
ethisches Dilemma denn die Antwort
entscheidet über Leben und Tod Kriterien
dafür will der Bundestag heute noch im
sogenannten triagegesetz beschließen
trotz scharfer Kritik aus Teilen der
Ärzteschaft und von Verbänden für
Menschen mit Behinderung zu den
Hintergründen Birgit Franka
Konstantin Grosch liebt mit einer
Behinderung der Politiker ist Corona
hochrisikopatient fürchtet auf der
Intensivstation benachteiligt zu werden
daher setzt er viele Hoffnung in das
neue triagegesetz doch mehr Schutz vor
Diskriminierung bringt es aus seiner
Sicht nicht nach der neuen Regelung ist
ausschlaggebend die aktuelle und
kurzfristige Überlebenschance nicht
berücksichtigt werden dürfen Alter und
Behinderung für die Entscheidung gilt
ein Vier-Augen-Prinzip
ja es ist richtig dass im
Gesetzesentwurf einerseits steht das
Behinderung Alter Geschlecht und andere
Gründe nicht berücksichtigt werden
sollen und dürfen aber wir wissen dass
eben die Ergebnisse von zum Beispiel
Behinderung also gesundheitliche
Einschränkungen dort mit hineinfallen
wenn man die
Überlebenswahrscheinlichkeit berechnet
vermutet oder wie auch immer Ärzte
dagegen begrüßen dass es auf die
Überlebenswahrscheinlichkeit ankommt sie
wollen möglichst viele Leben retten
daran hindert sie aus ihrer Sicht
allerdings dass die Regelung die
sogenannte ex-postriage verbietet heißt
wer ein intensivbett erhalten hat dem
darf es nicht wieder entzogen werden
auch wenn ein neuer Patient höhere
Überlebenschancen hätte wenn es eine
knappe Ressource gibt und mehr Patienten
die brauchen als wir sie haben dann muss
sie unter allen Patienten die sie
brauchen gerecht verteilt werden und
sonst haben wir ja praktisch einen
firstcam first Surf und das kann keine
richtige Entscheidung sein
eine Regelung am Rande des regelbaren
der Bundestag stimmt gerade darüber ab
es ist eine kaum vorstellbare Summe für
Kunst für gut 1,5 Milliarden Euro ist
ein Teil der Gemäldesammlung des
Verstorbenen microsoft-gründers Paul
Allen versteigert worden um 60
Meisterwerke ging es über diesem von
David hawkney der los soll so hat das
Ellen gewünscht größtenteils für
wohltätige Zwecke gespendet werden über
die einträglichste Versteigerung die es
im Auktionshaus Christie's bisher
gegeben hat berichtet Johannes Hanau
Rekorde mit Bietern aus 19 Ländern im
Raum zugeschaltet per Telefon und
Internet und mit über 2 Millionen
Zuschauern online für das Meisterwerk
von George Sara Gebote in Millionen
taktventile
130 Millionen Dollar der Rekord des
Abends versteigert an einen anonymen
Käufer in Asien
fünf Werke brachen gestern Abend die 100
Millionen Dollar Schallmauer darunter
dieser porzesan der Birkenwald von
Gustav Klimt Paul Gogo Girls Mütter und
van Goghs Obstplantage mit Zypressen
selbst für das erfolgsverwöhnte
Auktionshaus Christis ein besonderer
Abend das war natürlich toll weil dieses
dieses Summen für diese Bilder die
wirklich niemals an den Markt kommen
neue Käufer gefunden haben und zu sehr
hohen Preisen alle Bilder stammen aus
dem Nachlass von Paul Allen zusammen mit
Bill Gates hat der Microsoft
Mitbegründer Milliarden gemacht allen
war ein passionierter Kunstsammler er
wollte sich nicht festlegen auf nur eine
Epoche oder nur ein Stil einmalige
Kunstsammlung umfasst 500 Jahre
Kunstgeschichte von der Renaissance bis
zur zeitgenössischen Meisterwerken die
Vielfalt auch ein Grund für den Erfolg
der rekordversteigerung die Welt hat
gekauft weil es war ein Geschmack der
nicht national war es wären wirklich
internationaler Geschmack den wir heute
präsentiert haben
milliarden wurden allein gestern Abend
erzielt heute geht es weiter in New York
der Erlös soll nach Paul allens Willen
ausschließlich wohltätigen Zwecken
zugute kommen
und nun zur Fußball-Nationalmannschaft
da hat Bundestrainer Hansi Flick heute
seinen WM-Kader vorgestellt durchaus mit
Überraschung Norbert oder ja da gibt es
einen prominenten Rückkehrer nämlich
einen der Weltmeister von 2014 Mario
Götze von Eintracht Frankfurt und einen
blutjungen Debütanten jusufer mukoko vom
BVB der jüngste Spieler jemals in einen
deutschen WM-Kader berufen wurde wenig
überraschend setzt Hansi Flick auf den
sieben Mann starken bayern-blog vor
allem die Offensivkräfte um gnabry und
Co spielen derzeit überragend und sollen
auch bei der WM Druck machen die
Offensive stärken soll auch Neuling
Niklas Füllkrug der werder-stürmer bei
der Verkündung völlig überwältigt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
und noch ein nationalmannschaftsneuling
hat es in den Kader geschafft Dortmunds
super mukoko 17 Jahre alt könnte in
Katar der jüngste deutsche WM-Spieler
werden
er ist schnell heißt quirliger hat einen
guten Abschluss im März am Wochenende
auch gesehen hat von daher auch freuen
wir uns auf ihn in der Abwehr nicht
dabei 2014 Weltmeister Mats Hummels
diese nicht Nominierung bezeichnete
Hummels als eine der größeren
Enttäuschungen seiner Karriere klar das
er sehr enttäuscht ist weil das das
große Ziel war für ihn wir sind einfach
unglaublich glücklich dass Mats so so
gut spielt aktuell für uns Pechvogel
Marco Reus verpasst wie auch 2014 die WM
weil er nach seiner Fußverletzung noch
nicht fit genug ist dafür dabei nach
fünf Jahren ohne Länderspieleinsatz
Mario Götze der wm-final-torschütze von
2014 hat sich in Frankfurt zurück in den
Kader gekämpft da ist topfit er kann 90
Minuten auch dreimal die Woche gehen und
das ist natürlich schon eine gute
Voraussetzung und dann ist es einfach
auch ein genialer Fußballer und noch ein
toller Mensch 13 Tage bleiben Hansi
pflegt bis zum ersten WM-Spiel gegen
Japan
zur Fußball-Bundesliga Vorletzter
Spieltag vor der WM und da hat Leipzig
im Top-Duell gestern Abend gegen
Freiburg den 5 Pflichtspielsieg in Folge
gefeiert 3:1 gegen den SC RB rückt auf
Tabellenplatz 5 vor Freiburg jetzt
Dritter
Leipzig in weiß braucht Anlauf erst nach
ein paar mal Aluminium treffen die
Franzosen bei den Sachsen auch mal
zwischen die Pfosten Mohammed Sima kann
in der 55 Minute zum 1:0 die beste
bundesliga-abwehr wird eine Minute
später gleich noch mal geknackt
Christoph von kumku 2.0 nur 13
Gegentreffer hatte Freiburg vor dem
Spiel verbucht
Lukas Kübler erzielt 10 Minuten später
für die Gäste sehenswert den
Anschlusstreffer
ein umstrittener Foul Elfmeter
verwandelt von Emil Forsberg führte der
78 Minute zum 3:1 entstand seit Marco
Rose die Leipziger trainiert gibt es
daheim nur Heimsiege
und alle Tore alle Höhepunkte ist 14
Spieltags zusammen zugefasst wie immer
zu sehen bei
ZDF und in der ZDF heute-
noch einen ganz besonderen Glückwunsch
an die Kolleginnen und Kollegen von Logo
die zdf-kindernachrichten sind vor
wenigen Minuten mit dem Hans-joachim
Friedrichs Sonderpreis ausgezeichnet
worden für ihre achtsame und ehrliche
Berichterstattung über den Ukraine Krieg
die Begründung der Jury kein Thema ist
tabu Logo verzichte aber auf explizite
Bilder das sei der Weg und Kindern beim
Verstehen zu helfen und ihnen so die
Angst zu nehmen
und noch eine wichtige Nachricht kommt
heute vom Deutschen Wetterdienst laut
seiner saisonprognose erwartet uns ein
eher milder-winter alles zum aktuellen
Wetter erfahren Sie gleich von Katja
horneffer das heute mal können Sie im
21:45
[Musik]
guten Abend heute hielten sich Nebel und
Hochnebel zum Teil zäh hier im Osten
Deutschlands vor allen Dingen aber im
Hunsrück im Saarland und auch in der
Eifel dieser Nebel löste sich zum Teil
gar nicht auf und jetzt in der Nacht
wird er sogar wieder dichter werden viel
Nebel gibt es aber auch in
Süddeutschland klar ist es dagegen
zwischen der Lausitz und dem Niederrhein
über den Norden ziehen einige
Wolkenfelder hinweg und die Temperaturen
zeigen das übliche Herbstbild unter den
Wolken und in der Nähe des noch recht
Warmwassers von Nord und Ostsee bleibt
die Nacht mild bei 12 bis 10 Grad sonst
sinken die Werte auf 9 bis 4 Grad und in
Süddeutschland gehen die Temperaturen
auf +3 bis -1° zurück und morgen liegen
die Höchsttemperaturen Mais bei 11 bis
16 Grad hält sich der Nebel hartnäckiger
dann sind es nur so acht bis zehn Grad
und das könnte morgen zum Beispiel im
Donautal der Fall sein oder auch am
Bodensee sonst gibt es viel Sonnenschein
im Norden ein paar dichtere Wolkenfelder
und mit nebelhochnebel und Sonnenschein
haben wir es auch am Wochenende zu tun
das hochzieht weiter nach Osten zusammen
mit dem Tiefe mit dem Atlantik bleibt es
aber bei uns in Deutschland doch sehr
mild die Höchsttemperaturen liegen bei 7
bis 17 Grad erst am Montag gibt es im
Südwesten etwas Regen bis bald